[musique]
Lorsque les combats ont été introduits à Belogurovka, je suis arrivé ici
avec le dos et le voile et choqué sur nous
Cuve travaillée et étanche près de la pirogue
a volé et est arrivé ici avec un choc d'obus
déjà réalisé que la mémoire commence à disparaître
oublier et a commencé à oublier et à me parler
quand ils ont apporté quelque chose comme des accidents comme
J'ai été sorti j'étais très fort
tremblement des mains C'est-à-dire que tout le corps est si
bégayé
moi sur les nerfs nerfs et
bien sûr je m'inquiète pour aujourd'hui
pour sa dota bien lui pour sa fortune
c'est très dur, eh bien, maman elle-même est à Kupinsk
vécu et profession donc je ne suis personne
Je comprends ce que c'est, c'est la ligne
avant et comment c'est sous la grêle
mortiers le sens de la vie tu es ma fierté
mon tout
Et Bouddha va bien avec le mien
[musique]
juste mentir à la fois sera comme ça
stimulation magnétique à la fois que je passe
vous un tel procès
stimulé
anxiété
pour la tranquillité d'esprit
oui c'est plus facile
commencé à dormir la nuit
pour s'allonger arrêter
[musique]
il y aura des mains et des nattes flottant ici
Je ne catastrophiserais pas encore
blessure grave au côté de la dent
une chute
juste là murmurant des coups tous écrasés
pendant longtemps arraché et comme le vin alors
nous sommes dans quels axes pour survivre nous développons notre
[musique]
faites glisser ce que vous pouvez si au Canada alors
ils m'aideront dans la rééducation du dos
Voici un peu pour vous renouveler mentalement aussi
Je ne sais pas, ils les enverront plus loin
point chaud et tout
J'aimerais que mon anniversaire soit en mars
faire de la moto en mars
l'essentiel est de vivre chez soi
impossible
alors merci au patron il a dit tout ça
partir
votre état
sélectionnez actuellement cet état
comment pensez-vous que vous pouvez remettre
passé futur inconnu
Où te vois-tu ici
la peur qui reste aujourd'hui
jour c'est un avion
C'est-à-dire que tout allait bien dans la ville jusqu'à
commencé à larguer des bombes aériennes Eh bien, je
Je comprends que disons simplement qu'il fallait
survivre sans laisser de trace ne passe pas bien et
à quand la prochaine
arrivées à Kiev quand j'ai compris que
dans les airs nos avions sont tous pareils
certains craignent la panique
avait des problèmes de conflits de type familial
nous comprenons maintenant qu'il s'agit d'un problème mondial
l'ampleur du conflit et ici déjà
se connecte directement à notre
psyché ouais nous ne pouvons pas gérer
attaques de panique nous ne pouvons pas
nous ne pouvons pas gérer l'anxiété
faire face à une sorte de peur
que nous avons vécu à Marioupol Mais le même
corps déchirés oui quand on perd
proches, c'est la perte de l'étude
les pertes sont très difficiles à calculer ici
maintenant les gens et merci à notre
l'état est dit à notre monde très
reconnaissant que de tels projets soient gratuits
psychologues Oui que les gens commencent à aller
psychologues et comprendre pourquoi avant
n'a pas appliqué
[musique]